we don't want you Luke warm milk Liam
there start breaking bricks wet nips hi
I'm Jillian Bell and these are my
favorite videos on YouTube the first one
has got to be Jan Terry
get down Goblin it looks like it was
shot in another world there's a lot of
women walking around a castle awkwardly
and I mean I've mostly loved it because
it has the word goblin in it another
favorite of mine is Tim Curry anything
can happen on Halloween change
with anyone - I feel like everybody
should have seen this I'll be mad if you
haven't it is a scene from worst witch
the worst witch oh now I look terrible
okay I don't blame anyone if they
haven't see this just watch it because
of the rhyming one of my favorite lines
in it is he says something about green
and then he rhymes it with has anybody
seen my tambourine I love a blooper one
of my favorites is QVC hairdresser
blooper now watch when I flipped her
hair back did you see the difference of
this hair my god yeah very excited about
a woman who's calling it and he goes up
to like fake hug the camera I keep like
a cans at a time Falls and immediately
goes oh my booty booty thank you my
friend Selena showed me that props to
Selena this one is by far my favorite
video of all time on YouTube you just
have to type in ice skater farting
now the first time I saw that I was like
okay they caught an ice skater actually
like farting which is like ice skaters
don't have microphones on though so
there's no way someone is added we
should weep over the top fart sound
effects and there's one where he spins
in midair and it goes I'm not proud of
myself
[Music]
the last one I got it in with another
blooper cuz they're my favorite but
whatever I've had a bad day I look up
it's always sunny in philadelphia
bloopers you could tell that they really
liked hanging out with each other they
really genuinely made each other laugh
we don't want you Luke warm milk Liam
stop breaking bricks wet nips and
there's something about that that I just
love well that's kind of cool too
because that's what's more masculine
thanks for watching I hope you liked
these as much as I do
especially Tim Curry I love Tim Curry
you see that door right there man the
one mark pirate you think a pirate lives
in there I see a door marked private
mm-hmm is that the story you're talking
about